je poursuis ou sujet de cette importante
annonce du gouvernement le goût de main
avec kim la voix elle est titulaire de
la chaire de recherche du canada en
médecine comportementale et professeur
titulaire à lucas madame lavoie bonsoir
alors le gouvernement le goût devra
faire passer comprendre le message
demain il a vraiment obligation de
résultat n'est ce pas dans le contexte
pandémique actuelle au québec
oui je pense qu'on est on en est rendu
là et je fais même si on n'a pas réussi
à trouver la recette magique pour s'en
sortir de cette pandémie ici au québec
une chose est claire qu'est ce qu'on a
fait jusqu'à maintenant ça ne marche pas
alors je pense que c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement commence à envisager des
consignes sanitaires strictes à partir
de demain
cela dit ça fait quand même presque plus
du mot en fait qu'on est au convie cette
pandémie là et on fait qu'il ya une
fatigue on la ressent toute cette
fatigue mentale ces restrictions que
l'on vit dans nos familles dans nos
proches avec mon enfant et tout ça est
ce qu'on doit passer le message
différemment comment s'y prendre pour
qu'on continue d'adhérer à ces consignes
center la première marche parce que les
conseils doit maintenir une certaine
cohérence et je crois que l'une des
raisons pourquoi on observe encore des
gens qui sont récalcitrants qui qui qui
semble pas vouloir observer au conseil
c'est que on attend toujours des
recommandations on dit s'il vous plaît
ce métier en solaire et en solidarité
pour s'en sortir mais ça qu'on a des
règlements clairs avec les conséquences
non seulement négative comme on va voir
les amendes si on respecte pas les
consignes mais aussi à 3 s'attendre
côté positif si on se mettre ensemble
pour le vrai et ont réussi à s'en sortir
alors je crois qu'il faut avoir une
cohérence dans les stratégies et quand
il ya de l'espace sud ou de la
conclusion de la forme les gens qu'on
peut avoir 25 personnes à de l'église
les on peut pas avoir ces personnes
autour de la table
je crois que c'est ça qui fait que les
gens questionne les consignes et la sas
à sa botte un peu la crédibilité d
globalement alors en d'autres mots le
gouvernement d'abord devrait plus
coercitif à ce que vous estimez qu'on a
qu'on devrait dominer d'aventuré
sanctionner davantage les fautifs
étaient excellents question je crois
pour changer le comportement des gens
l'idéal c'est de les motiver
comment combative déjà c'est qu'on leur
montre à quelle quelle mesure observées
aux consignes va être bénéfique pour eux
personnellement mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui prend du temps et
malheureusement je pense qu'avec le taux
de cas qu'on observe à ce jour là au
québec on a perdu le contrôle de la
pandémie ici et on a plus de temps pour
pour inciter pour motiver les gens avec
ces stratégies
habituellement très efficace ce temps là
à passer et malheureusement si on veut
changer le comportement des gens à court
terme il faut être clair il faut être
ici il faut que les gens qu'on prend
qu'est ce qui va arriver si on respecte
pas les conseillers et je crois aussi qu
une sortie un aspect strict dans les
consignes sa trombine le massage aussi
que c'est important le fait courir
toujours voyagé que c'est pas écrit les
squares laisse croire aux gens que c'est
correct des ces derniers c'est pas
dangereux à la persistance été dangereux
mais ce serait effectivement étape
alors si je vous suis bien dans l'état
actuel des choses de la courbe
pandémique au québec c'est plus le temps
d'essayer de convaincre s'il faut être
plus plus plus dur que ce soit oui je
crois que la question du star c'est un
élément très important si on se fie
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui a fonctionné
dans d'autres pays jeu phare de
l'australie par exemple qui est un pays
très similaire à nous mais en fait
qu'est ce qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont
réussi à faire ce qu'ils y ont réussi à
prendre le contrôle la pandémie très
rapidement avec un resserrement
fermeture un confinement rapide mais
cours et le fait que c'était court que
je parle de quatre à cinq semaines
sall a contribué à augmenter le niveau
d'adhérence adhésion des gens parce que
c'était justement
pour je crois qu'au québec le problème
c'est que on a l'impression qu'on compte
qu'on réagit un peu à la mitaine ont
fait une petite affaire pour quelques
semaines petite affaire pour un mois et
on revient dans quelques semaines pour
revoir et c'est très douce et pour les
gens de fonctionner à long terme comme
ça sans savoir c'est quoi le plan à long
terme
oui mais en même temps est-ce qu'on peut
avoir la certitude que si on fait comme
l'australie qu'on applique donc un
confinement très stricte avec une durée
donnée
on va voir le résultat attendu est ce
qu'on peut avoir cette certitude là et
ça serait ccpt est possible d'avoir des
certitudes mais comme chercheur on doit
se fier aux données
c'est pas mon opinion qui compte celi
données qui compte et on voit que qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait en australie qui
l'ont fait en nouvelle zélande
sall a fonctionné et c'est parmi les
îles et des pays avec les les
restrictions les puces trait au monde et
on sait que à l'heure actuelle ils
traitent très brute record et ont réagi
très vite à partir de 25 ans et on vise
à permettre au total de la région
affectée
allez on sait que ayant réussi alors ils
les données de la santé publique et il
ya tout le reste on peut lui dire toutes
les autres secteurs de la société voilà
avec quoi le gouvernement le beau joe
ingles aura demain je vous remercie
infiniment madame lavoie au revoir merci
beaucoup merci